any potential autoimmune issues that might be happening due to the ketruda.
Well, you can't really combat them until they happen.
So, most people that are going to take the mutal therapy, like ketruda,
that's one brand of a mutal therapy, are going to end up with an autoimmune issue.
You just are. You just can't prevent them.
Because the whole, what mutal therapy does is it blocks the receptor site on the T cells on your T cells.
So, your lymphocytes break down into natural killer cells into T cells.
And that's when it kills kids or are those two things.
Well, the T cells have a receptor site that your human body cells attach to and then it tells the T cells not to kill your body cells.
So, what if you don't therapy like ketruda does is it blocks that receptor site so that your T cells will kill the cancer.
Well, they'll also kill your human body cells and you'll end up with autoimmune diseases.
So, you could get any type of inflammation, those cuddling will be colitis, but you're on ketruda.
So, you just got to deal with it when you get it and just try to heal the colon and you can't necessarily prevent it.